hey everyone what's up welcome to
another thoughts video from the
simulation team I'm Alan sockin I'm
gonna be talking to you about Kanye West
and our thoughts on Kanye West so as we
start we're gonna flip over our handy 15
minute timer it's gonna help us keep
track of time so as you guys know these
videos are to try and distill and
disseminate all of the variables and
nuance that is going on in the media and
in the sphere of all the communications
about certain topics and we're trying to
really be a disseminator as well as
highlight all of the nuance and multi
variability so we're trying to not
polarize trying to not be binary but
trying to really unpack all the
variables and we're coming at you hot
with some info on Kanye today so some of
our thoughts on Kanye first thought it's
really important to remember his history
Kanye is 40 now Kanye is one of the best
rappers of all time and with the weight
of being the best rapper of all time
comes a lot of depression anxiety fame
money drugs women cars houses all that
stuff that's a lot for people to handle
I mean that's ridiculous and it usually
ends people in the same place that Kanye
went to which was needing to get some
sort of help from hospitalization and
just getting some sort of therapy to get
over things so I just he's really been
on a hero's journey Kanye has absolutely
been on hero's journey he's been going
through a lot of ups and downs to get to
where he is today and I think that's
really important to recognize and
understand and also just be with how
difficult his hero's journey has been
like take into account that the same guy
that raps about things like the the
California Corrections agency meanwhile
the CCA teamed up with the DEA they
trying to lock up they try and make new
slaves
at lying right there is talking about
the corporate Corrections of America
teaming up with the DEA and locking up
more black people because of recidivism
and they're going a lot to marijuana
related crimes and that's just a
revolving door of nonsense and that's
it's for-profit prison systems so Connie
has some really good lyrics throughout
his music so for those that haven't you
know not that much respect for what he
says I mean he's got a lot of good
lyrics in his music he also definitely
still talks about some of the same kind
of like like money women jewelry drugs
cars etc and you know at the same time
those things are a little bit less like
meaningful there's something good about
really striving to attain goals of
things that you want to achieve but at
the same time materialism conspicuous
consumption and escapism are not they
don't cause self-actualization so so
it's been so just to highlight on his on
his music there's been some really good
stuff coming from his music over the
years as well so now with all of this
Fame that's come up and I really hope
that he and jay-z make watched thrown to
think some of you guys know that about
where I stand I really want to see
washing thrown to come out so as as he's
evolved through his ups and downs of the
hero's journey he said crazy things
happened to him like what happened in
Paris with Kim Kardashian getting robbed
you know first of all the fact that he
and Kim became a power couple is very
interesting and there's just some sort
of like a dynamic of power there that is
fascinating just like jay-z and Beyonce
and a bunch of other power couples
across the planet that that's an
interesting thing thing that happens
especially like in India we were
recently hearing about one of our
friends that was kidding set up to
become married to a man so that her mom
could get a house from the man's family
as in the Maenads family was going to
by her mama house and she was supposed
to marry the guy for that and so there's
all these weird power couple dynamics
that go around on around the earth and
arranged marriages and things like that
so it's it's kind of a crazy dynamic in
the first place and then so be happy for
your freedoms and so when you do end up
marrying somebody else that's really
wealthy and famous you're almost
inevitably going to complicate your life
further with that and then also
complicate the life of your children
with that as well
who knows that might be better for your
kids Klout it might be better for their
future to marry to for you to marry
somebody in a power position of power so
I find that to be very interesting that
even happen and then Kanye wasn't there
when Kim Kardashian got robbed for her
jewelry and then Connie said that he
stopped carrying around jewelry in his
house jewelry there's no jewelry or
expensive things in areas where his kids
are now which is very strums traumatic
it's traumatic to experience that and
it's traumatic to experience that for
his wife as well for their safety so
there was also another time that he said
that he was at the hospital and that he
had his friends escorted away from him
by the hospital staff and then he was
just with only the hospital staff and he
thought he was going to die he thought
they were going to kill him and I know
that seems like an anxious and paranoid
thought but at the same time isn't that
so true though when there is no one that
you know around you anymore
and at any point someone can inject you
with whatever to cause your heart to
stop I mean that's some because of money
because somebody's trying to kill you
for money so that you can die so they
can make money because your competition
with them so it's especially with all
the things that have happened to him in
the past like that that's a really
touching story for me for me I really
feel for him throughout all those lows
as he's gotten back up and ridden on
these highs to make the life of Pablo
and not to make helped produce Daytona
so that and this is an interesting point
this is why he goes to Wyoming I
we went to Utah as well but basically
they they have their production now I
don't know how much of it exactly is
happening in Wyoming in Jackson Hole but
I think that this is really interesting
is that wealthier humans are starting I
know Sun Valley Idaho is another place
like this but wealthier humans are
starting to now get like second homes
even third homes or whatever in these
like remote locations that are much
further away from the metropolis is in
nature so they can be connected to earth
to Gaia to Pachamama to the energy of
nature and not to the energy of like
concrete and computers and cubicles and
stuff like that so that's why they go
out there to produce and to be
distracted away from all of the crazy
metropolis social media internet
entertainment stuff so they can go there
just produce beats and produce songs and
so I think that's one of the reasons why
they're doing that is because it's
therapeutic to get away from that and
get into nature so that's something that
you know that we practice here is we go
out into nature we aim for at least like
once a week to go out and connect to the
earth like that
whether it be oceans or redwood trees
and hiking or wherever it ends up being
so that actually ends up stirring up a
lot of creative potential so I don't
know how many of you guys have gotten
the chance to hear Daytona yet I
recommend going and listening to it
there's some powerful lyrics in there
but a lot of what I really like about
Daytona is the beats I really really
like the beats a lot the beats that were
produced there are really good beats in
my opinion I like him a lot and so go
check that out because it was recently
dropped let's push a tease album I think
yet produced a good amount of the beats
if not all of them I don't know exactly
so yeah also is talking about and so
this is Kanye Kanye is also yay or easy
so for future reference I think most of
you know that so EA was also talking
about strategy and strategy and thoughts
versus feelings I don't this was really
interesting so yeah he's coming from a
place of the heart right he was talking
about heart energy versus the thinking
the strategizing he's like everyone's
trying to move [ __ ] around and be like
pawns in each other's puzzles and
or kings or queens and controlling pawns
and like moving money around and doing
business and stuff and that's a lot of
the ego and the strategizing and
thinking talking but when we take a
break and we dip into our hearts we
really start feeling and when we feel we
understand the other person's a human
and that we're not here to just monetize
and capitalize on other people but we're
here to feel their hearts and to be with
them to be this divinity that we were
given to be in the cosmos and we say
this whole hop but the fact that your
mom and dad and their mom and dad and
their mom and dad and their mom and dad
and their mom and dad all screwed all
[ __ ] and had a sperm and egg meat and
and be grown inside of themselves and in
order to birth the next generation in
birth the next generation birth the next
generation that had those just stations
over and over again and produced you and
every human is that divine being but it
squelched the aperture of divinity is
closed our signal connection divinity
it's closed by culture and so yay has
been has had as clothes like hero's
journey closed and open and closed and
open and so I think that by talking
about strategy and feeling strategy
versus feeling I think he's really
opening up a new way of thinking for a
lot of people cuz he's coming from him
he's got a lot of people that listen to
him
so his hero's journey is also really
interesting because he talks a lot about
making it and being pure and so I think
this is really interesting because you
know even ron has talked to me about
this in the past a lot of people have
talking with us and I've been analyzing
this in a lot of people as well but it's
really difficult to stay pure while you
make it because typically what ends up
happening is a good amount of Fame or
success or money or whatever comes in
and people change people change so
[ __ ] much that's why I'm very clear
when I talk to you guys about not
wanting to buy any watches not wanting
to buy any
means not worrying about any jewelry I
don't want any boats no planes no cars
I just want to rent [ __ ] and just use it
just for the time being to like go from
point A to point B no renting jewelry we
don't need that [ __ ] or watch it's like
we don't need that [ __ ] that's fancy
shit's unnecessary what's more necessary
is increasing our impact we talk about
that a lot and so that's where like
Kanye and I kind of you know we separate
off because not only unlike that
conspicuous consumption side of things
but this new clothing line easy I'm not
really as big of a fan of having like a
multi-billion dollar clothing line that
sells I don't know how I'm not I'm not
exactly sure about how much this costs
are for producing a shirt or sweater or
whatever and whatever is on it and
people find profound or whatever you
know hopefully we can do something like
that but again a lot of what our
clothing has said in the past is like
are we in a computer simulation or who
will teach robots ethics like the idea
is just to provoke thought and and to
keep things kind of on the cheaper side
of things so more people can afford them
and wear them so I hope it's not some
like Louis Vuitton like hundred dollar
white t-shirt thing so I wonder if it's
true that people can that make money can
be pure because that's a really
important thing to think about making
money and staying pure making impact and
staying pure so that way your ego
doesn't go and get way too ahead of you
but you can stay calm and you can stay
humble and you can continue making
impact without get letting your ego get
ahead of you and just stay pure and we
think that five amiyo DMT meditation
things like that helped a lot with that
process as well of ego eradication so
this is all very interesting things in
parts of Kanye's hero's journey and
these little bits of what he's been
teaching he also taught about these
tools he was like as you're climbing up
the mountain like kind of like the
heroes during the climbing up the
mountain you see some really good tools
at the top but you only realize when you
get to the top usually that the tools
that you gained along the way of
climbing the mountain were better than
the tools at the top of the mountain I
thought that was a really interesting
analogy from yay alright moving on to
the second point
so we're almost done with our first 15
minutes timer and I got to I got two
more of these points all right
this point is about victimisation verse
economic development and I think this is
a pressing point and it's kind of
happening a lot it's a lot of
conversations are happening about it
today I made a post recently about how I
thought that that a lot of victimization
a lot of people be saying that they're
victims it's actually has a direct
impact alongside people being
megalomaniacs so people that are overly
typical about exerting power and control
over other people are causing a lot of
other people to feel like victims and to
say that they're victims
so I think they're directly related in
that sense and then people I'd say
they're victims make megalomaniacs think
oh I can take more advantage now and
stuff so that's just a heads up that
those things are intertwined and
interrelated and so it's not as simple
as just saying like you know slavery was
a choice or that it wasn't a choice or
that I'm a victim or I'm not a victim
but things are very complex and mold
very nuanced and multivariate and we'd
love to sit down with Connie and talk to
him about these things in the nuance
because I think there's a good way that
we could sit down with him and talk to
him about things to open people up for
example with like with economic
development when was the last time that
that on the news it wasn't about
victimhood but it was about by the way
here's how to buy property and here's
how to buy stocks you know and that's a
really good point if you go to sauce
Chicago and you go and you try and teach
people about how to buy property and buy
stocks I think that's really [ __ ]
important and I think that that would
help launch off up areas into better
economic development rather than just
victimization so I thought that was
really interesting he also made some
comments about like Harriet Tubman being
on the $20 bill and how he thought that
that was some still some old slave [ __ ]
he's said to put Michael Jordan on the
$20 bill instead I thought that was kind
of interesting I think
Tubman is obviously Rosa Parks people
like that are huge forces for good MLK
and Malcolm and stuff but at the same
time I think that you know he's also
kind of right which is that like make it
real like and put Oprah on it you know
put someone that is like a successful
but I put Obama on it right put someone
that's a successful black figure from
today that doesn't have anything to do
with slavery on the bill so that way
people have something to aspire to
achieve and to become because they see
that oh by the way if if Paul can do it
so can Roger right
if Sally can do it so can Shawn oh right
so that's not that's the general idea is
that you want to see other people like
you that have succeeded so that way you
can also be like I can succeed too and
you can get the benefit from your family
a lot of this less to do with the social
fabric conversation that we haven't
unpacked in enough detail yet we try on
the show a lot but as we strengthen the
social fabric it's not only about
picking yourself up from your bootstraps
and going forth into the world in actual
izing but also the social fabric around
you becoming better and tighter and
actualizing people as well in the
communities around them so having our
basic needs more easily met so yeh said
that he wants to become the greatest
real estate developer of all time and he
wants to build cities which I find
interesting I wonder what yay cities
will be like and that the fact that he
wants to build a real estate again you
already know me I'm not sure about real
estate I think a lot of people are gonna
be renting for a really long time and I
think that has to do with the fact that
people don't want to own they don't want
to have 20 or 30 your mortgages on
things so and I think that the future is
gonna be a lot different with like
location agnosticism like people are
gonna want to just like travel and move
to different places sometimes but people
will want homes and you know it'll be
complicated but it'll be interesting
what exactly is gonna have with the
housing market so I don't know if you
guys heard his song lift yourself right
lift yourself get up on if you get
yourself up Bonnie fee
let's get it on lift yourself Bonnie fee
that's good it all right and so like
that is kind of like that lifts yourself
and then also build a better social
fabric and like confidence is a crucial
part of that right we need to have a lot
of confidence moving forward in order to
be able to actualize you know he brought
up aha 15 minutes heimer flip him back
over you know he brought up like the
fact that he was trying to talk to
Zuckerberg and some of Zuckerberg
connections about getting evaluations
for his company and that he didn't get
connected to the right people and I
thought that was interesting that
there's like something that that that
people are trying to keep him
misinformed
I wonder how accurate that is and how I
wonder how like what those dynamics are
with people like you know there's plenty
of times that I reach out to really
successful people and I'm trying to
engage with them and I've never really
thought about it before like the reason
why they're not engaging back with me is
because they're trying to keep me
misinformed and so I wonder how often
that's happening because I don't think
I'm doing that to other people but but I
think that's really important to talk
about seems as though that hopefully
nobody's ever trying to keep other
people misinformed or at least if you
want to hold back information because
the secret just you know be like sorry I
can't like talk about that right now or
whatever so he's you know he and I are
similar in the sense Kanye and I are
similar in the sense that we're trying
to learn as much as possible about the
world and so he has other people that he
delegates to learn things so I wonder if
he has people learning about blockchain
and about quantum computing and about
all these different crazy industries
that are emerging so I thought I thought
this was interesting about artists as
scientists needed gateway drug to
business so like he was talking about
artists he's like artists get managers
and then artists get this manager that
manager that manager so the artist stays
very misinformed about all these things
and they can get taken advantage of so
the artist never has like an
pío right and so yeh was talking about
the importance of having an artist build
up their own brand and learn about these
different things that managers do so
that way they don't have to get taken
advantage of that they can figure out
how to do it a lot of it themselves and
they can be up to at least intellectual
conversation about these things and
again a lot of people are trying to
strategize on them rather than have
feelings connecting each other and so
like imagine if scientists and artists
had a gateway to business and so that's
a really important thing like we have
friends at Indy bio and we I mentor
there is that having scientists turn
into entrepreneurs is really important
same thing with the artist turned into
entrepreneurs on sites like patreon like
what we do so I thought this was really
cool as well it was this idea that music
and boxing has made more people [ __ ]
than rich and at first when I heard that
I was like that's probably true right
that more people are [ __ ] than rich
because they focus too much of their
time on these lyrics that are
meaningless or the focuses too much on
time on getting their brain smash and
stuff and they're so few in artists and
so few in boxers that actually make it
to people that make money that make it
like really good money so I thought that
was a really interesting phrase he also
talked about how Obama is the Jackie
Robinson of politics because he didn't
talk about racism every single moment
that he had and the yays relationship
with Obama is a little bit a little bit
strange for a different time but but the
fact that yeah Obama we never talked
about like racism that every single time
that he had the ability to he was
focused on on not talking about racism
and not making that like some massive
massive deal and telling people that
they're victims to racism but rather how
can we get people to think that about
economic empowerment economic
development but also tighten that social
fabric so there is less racism as well
absolutely all right
and
no no if you guys watch the TMZ
interview I highly recommend watching
him on TMZ and with Charlamagne both
those two Charlamagne and TMZ two
separate videos but he walked across TMZ
to a guy that was disagreeing with him
about slavery and he walked across TMZ
knee hugged it so I think that requires
a very grounded person a loving person
kind person to walk over there and say
like I love you even though we disagree
I love you and he did and he went and
said that across to someone that was not
feeling the same thing he was feeling I
think that's important for us to
understandings that were humans first
and there are ideas come second and so I
think it's important for us to love one
another first and then discuss these
ideas in a thoughtful and productive way
so just thinking about being a victim
and economic development how do we bring
more economic development and prosperity
tightening that social fabric getting
people actualized rather than absorbing
a victimhood mentality at all times so
alright so we have that we have yeas
roller coaster and now we're gonna talk
about EA talking about simulations
because he talks about simulation theory
so much and I wish we had more content
of him talking about simulation theory
but yay talking about simulation theory
has been really interesting because
obviously our shows called simulation
and we would like to really extend
hitting invite to come on the show talk
about this but the notion that he
mentions the matrix all the time like
that civilization is the matrix like
when he was going through the process of
like anxiety and depression and all
these all these consumption and
materials and all these things that
pressures that were forming around him
that he decided that like that he was in
the matrix he was literally in the
matrix seeing other people in the matrix
as well and being in the hospital being
in the matrix and so he talks about it a
lot and I think that's really
interesting because he wants to break
out of the simulation and one of the
best ways to feel like you're breaking
out of the simulation is to actually be
a free thinker
so you'll notice that yay talks about
like how the media is a big trap in that
the narrative is not actually the
narratives actually not even like
positive at all it's it doesn't vibe
that well with like Millennials and Gen
Sears that are trying to find meaning or
purpose in life and so yeah is very
clear about about how that's the matrix
and people are lost in the matrix
they're lost in the simulation we need
to help them break through and how
especially people in like South Side
Chicago and stuff they're also lost in
the matrix just like a lot of other
people on the on the planet are and I
think I'm slowly breaking through that
as well and hopefully that I can move
out and be more of a free thinker and
not have my opinions be controlled by a
mainstream narrative that's my fear and
then algorithms on my devices that are
just feeding me the things that they
know that I'm gonna be raged about so to
break through that and break through
that control of people being controlled
by the media and move forward it
requires free thinking and it requires
open-mindedness to free thinking and to
learning from other people and to not be
a conspicuous consumer but to be a
creator so I think him talking about
breaking through the simulations
fascinating and he kind of did that with
Taylor Swift as you guys remember when
she won the award because he came on a
stage and he broke the simulation he
made an interruption and he talked about
someone else should have won the award
so I think when we talk about hacking
the simulation I think Connie and I have
a very similar vibe about that because
in order to actually get to the point we
need a we need to run our own
simulations and we need to see
civilizations form and once we've seen
them form we can make a better analysis
of where they've come and see ourselves
exactly in the simulated world that
we've made and then we look back and
we're like whoa that's the same
evolutionary track this planet orbiting
the star because we simulated it
and look at all these other rocks
orbiting stars and so I think letting go
of a lot of the negativity and trauma
that's built up and the species is so
crucial species species trauma I'm
moving forward and actualizing and both
as a self and collective so it's so
interesting that that that Kanye has
went through this crazy hero's journey
it's one of the best rappers of all time
but has also went through these bits of
drama drama and trauma and then has now
been a driving force for getting
economic empowerment and economic
development into people rather than
victimhood victimization and we could
like simulation theory so much I find
really interesting and really
fascinating so I want to thank you guys
for tuning in to this episode on Kanye
our thoughts on Kanye West if you guys
had a good time share the content with
other people let's get some more
thoughts circulating about Kanye give us
a comment below with your thoughts
subscribe and like the content of course
join the family also create with this
content go and write something about
what your thoughts are on what's going
on in in the simulation world or in the
hero's journey that Kanye's went through
or in the economic empowerment world and
how we should be focusing on that and or
make a video or make any content make
content create don't just consume with
it and then also we'll be making more
thoughts videos soon a lot of this again
is us taking in all this information and
disseminating it we have you know a
couple thought videos on dave rubin and
candice owens charlie kirk jordan
peterson and Elon Musk and now Kanye
West so we'll keep making these thoughts
videos for you guys so keep sharing them
across especially pages where people
talk about mosque and Petersen and West
and all these other people so do give it
a share across those pages and yeah help
us out if this content was useful
definitely join us on patreon so we can
continue sustaining the studio space and
keep learning and growing and building
great content for you and keep building
cool productions and live events so
thanks everyone for tuning in
we'll catch you guys soon peace